this might be the last video if i can
squeeze in three problems so problem 14
the last video at least for sat prep
hopefully i will keep doing videos
okay and it looks something like this
and it comes back down like this and
what are they telling us they're saying
that this
this is line
line l line m
this is x
this is z degrees
this is y degrees looks like we have to
play the angle game and the figure above
lines l are parallel to line m or line l
is parallel to line and there's only one
l
what does z equal in terms of x and y
okay so these two
lines are parallels if this is y degrees
what other angles are also y degrees
well what's the corresponding angle on
right here well this is also going to be
y degrees right these lines are parallel
this is a transversal these are
corresponding angles it's going to be y
and it makes sense to i mean if you
tilted this angle you would visually see
that these angles would be the same
if this is y what is this angle well
they're opposite so this is also going
to be y
and then we have z plus x plus y is
actually has to equal 180 right because
they're all in the same triangle
z plus x plus y is equal to 180.
we want to solve for z so subtract x and
y from both sides and you get z is equal
to 180 minus x minus y
and that is choice e
next problem
problem 15
if
n over
n minus 1
times 1 over n
times
n
over
n plus 1 is equal to 5 over k
for positive integers n and k what is
the value of k so these are positive
integers
so before multiplying all of this out we
can simplify a little bit this n can
cancel out with this n
and now let's see if we can
so what is the top what does this
left-hand side become and the numerator
always left this is just a 1 now this is
a 1. so we're left with 1 times 1 times
n so that's n
over
n minus 1 n minus 1 times 1. i can
ignore that 1 times n plus 1
times n plus 1
is equal to
over k
so what are they asking oh what is what
is the value of k
well we can say that
n is equal to five
or let's assume that n is equal to five
because we don't know definitely that n
is equal to five it could be you know
some multiple we'll i'll show you let's
assume that n is equal to five
if n is equal to 5
then what is k well then k would be this
denominator
right if n is 5 then k is this
then k would be
so this could be
5 over
5 minus 1 times 5 plus 1
and that equals 5 over
4 times 6
which is equal to 5 over 24
so this could be 5 over 24. and they're
all positive integers so k is 24
k is 24 and that's choice c
so the trick here is really once again
you know simplify a little bit multiply
that and then pattern matching let me
just set
n is equal to 5. if n is equal to 5 then
what is k
it's 5 minus 1 times 5 plus 1 just
pattern matching
next problem
problem 6.
i will do it in magenta because this is
the last problem in the book
to celebrate a colleague's graduation
the m co-workers in an office agreed to
contribute equally to a catered lunch
that costs a total of y dollars
so there's m workers
m workers
and the total price is y dollars for the
lunch
if p of the workers failed to contribute
which of the following represents the
additional amount in dollars
that each of the remaining co-workers
must contribute to pay for the lunch
the additional amount in dollars so if
everyone paid how much would we have to
pay
well the total lunch is y right
so if everyone was a good coworker we
would each have to pay y divided by the
number of coworkers
right this is the ideal situation
but we know some of the coworkers didn't
pay
p didn't pay so how many are we going to
have to divvy it up now with so then
that means only m minus p paid
right these are the these are the dead
beats that did not pay for the launch so
only the m minus p paid so now we have
to actually
divide the y dollars on between a
smaller group of people who actually
paid and the smaller group of people who
actually paid is m minus p
so if you wanted to figure out and this
is going to be a larger number why
because this denominator is smaller when
the denominator is smaller you have the
same numerator there's going to be a
larger number
so if you wanted to know
how what is the additional amount you
have to pay
well this is how much we're having to
pay
which is a larger amount than how much
we would have paid if everyone paid so
how much we paying extra well we
subtract this from this this is how much
we end up paying
and this is and we subtract how much we
should have paid
and we'll get the additional amount
right let me draw a line just to get
confused so then how do we
that doesn't look like one of the
choices so let's actually get a common
denominator common denominator would be
m
times
m minus p all right i just multiply the
denominators
so y over m minus p that's the same
thing as
m
y over m times n minus p i just multiply
the numerator and denominator by m
and this is minus minus where
m minus p times y minus
m minus p times y
right i just for this one i just
multiply the numerator and denominator
by m minus p
right i just found a common denominator
and added the fractions or subtracting
the fractions and so
the the denominator stays m times m
minus p let me see if i can simplify the
numerator
that becomes m
y
minus m
plus p y right minus times the minus y
is plus plus p y these cancel out so you
get p y
over m times m minus p
and that is choice
that is choice e
that is choice e p y over m times m
minus p
and we have now done something like what
eight tests and eight tests and 54
problems per test so that's 54 times
eight
54 times eight that's what
432 sat problems and i think you're
ready to go take the sat and
get a perfect score
and let me know if you do that'd be very
exciting all right i'll see you in i
guess other videos that are non-sat
related or maybe when a new book comes
out i'll have to do this again i'll see
you soon